ويل سميث وجوني ديب في جده انطلاق فعاليات
مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي
ليله روائع النباطي في الرياض انفصال يوسف
الشريف ورحيل اشرف عبد الغفور اليكم
الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع بجراه اكبر في اطلالات النجمات على
السجاده الحمراء مقارنه بالدورين
السابقتين بحضور جوني ديب وويل سميث ونخبه
من المع نجوم السينما في العالم وبرنامج
غني من الافلام العربيه والسينمائيه
العالميه التي تعرض لاول مره في الشرق
الاوسط من بينها 36 فيلما سعوديا انطلقت
فعاليات الدوره الثالثه من مهرجان البحر
الاحمر السينمائي الدولي في مدينه جده
السعوديه في حفل شهد تكريم رانفير سينغ
الذي وصفه القائمون على المهرجان برمز
السينما الهنديه والممثله الالمانيه دايان
كروجر وال الفنان السعودي عبد الله
السدحان وفي ليله الافتتاح تم عرض الفيلم
السعودي حوجا للمخرج ياسر الياسري وتدور
احداثه عن جني سحري يجد نفسه مفتونا
بعائله بشريه تعيش في المنزل نفسه لكنها
لا تستطيع رؤيته وعلى هامش الدوره الثالثه
من مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي
تم استضافه فعاليه المراه في السينما التي
تحتفي بالمساهمات النسائيه السينمائيه وتم
بهذه المناسبه تكريم احدى ايقونات السينما
المصريه الفنانه نبيله عبيد اعترافا
بمسيرتها الفنيه
الراسخه
خفيف الظل هذا السحر ومن مهرجان البحر
الاحمر السينمائي الدولي في مدينه جده
السعوديه الى موسم الرياض الذي شهد
الاسبوع الماضي ليله روائع النباطي تكريما
لذكرى الموسيقار المصري الراحل رياض
النباطي شدى في هذه الليله نخبه من
المطربين المصري ين والعرب بمختارات من
الحان النباط الخالده واختتمت المطربه
المصريه شيرين عبد الوهاب باداء رائعه
كوكب الشرق الراحله ام كلثوم حيرت قلبي
معك
[موسيقى]
وصور روحي وعزت نفسي
منعاني وعزه نفسي
[موسيقى]
منع وفي موسم الرياض اقيمت الاسبوع الماضي
منافسات المهرجان العالمي اللاب الذي حقق
تفاعلا على منصات التواصل في العالم
العربي عند الاعلان
عنه واحتفالا بعيد الاتحاد الاني لدوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده احيا حسين
الجسمي احلام وبلقيس حفلا جماهيريا في ابو
ظبي انشد فيه الجسمي النشيد الوطني
الاماراتي بعزف منفرد على اله البيانو حقق
تفاعلا على منصات التواصل
بلادي
بلادي بلادي
حماك
الاله شرور
السما ومن الاخبار الفنيه التي حققت
تفاعلا واسعا على منصات التواصل في مصر
خبر انفصال الفنان المصري يوسف الشريف عن
انجي علاء بعد زواج دام 14 عاما وقد اعلنا
الخبر في بيان مشترك عبر حسابيهما
الرسميين على منصه
اكس
[موسيقى]
وتعاون الثنائي الذي انفصل مؤخرا في عده
اعمال فنيه قدم يوسف مسلسل لعبه ابليس عن
قصه لانجي وكتبت له سيناريو مسلسل كوفيد
25 ومثلت فيه الى جانبه ومن المقرر ان
يقدم مسلسل الراكون في
2024 من تاليفها
ايضا ونختتم الابرز لهذا الاسبوع بخبر
رحيل الفنان المصري القدير اشرف عبد
الغفور والد الفنانه المصريه ريهام عبد
الغفور عن عمر 81 عاما متاثرا بجراحه في
حادث مروري مدلا الستار على مسيره فنيه
غنيه امتدت قرابه الخ عاما وقدم الفنان
الراحل اخر ادواره التلفزيونيه بمسلسل
رشيد في موسم دراما رمضان الماضي كده
بقى واضح ان الحل مش من
هنا